I will challenge Nigel Faraj to a public
open debate about whether we should be
in or out of the opinion because that is
now the choice facing this country Mr
Farage is very much over to you the ball
and is in your court nearly choked on my
bacon roll what I heard Nick Clegg say
he wanted to have a debate you're ready
to go to take on click on the LBC debate
I can hardly wait suicide I believe the
best people govern Britain are the
British people with the British people
the British people themselves we're no
longer asking if Britain will have a
referendum we are asking when Britain
will have a referendum they all want us
trapped inside this European Union's we
want to make our own laws in our own
country in our own Parliament the
Liberal Democrats will lead the way as
the party of in UK want out of Europe or
if the Lib Dems are the party of in the
party of in we are unashamedly patriotic
in this party and ungenerous backwards
looking politics we believe in this
country politics of blame has found an
acceptable face he wears a big smile
looks like someone you could have a
paint booth down the pub
they've got the train the other night
that was until after we got past Grove
Park that I could actually hear English
before to be spoken in the carriage does
that make me feel slightly awkward yes
you're underneath this your liberal
Democrat I am indeed yeah we are not
auntie Europe I'm married to a woman
who's Spanish my mother is Dutch
we don't think sodom and gomorrha begins
at Calais oh stop apologizing for having
people with European passports under the
roof of my home being in Europe means
being in work my job is to persuade the
great British public but in now other
part of the world do we need to be part
of the political union in order to go on
doing business